Okay.
Thanks Miroslav.
Welcome Professor Blair
I'm going to do
just a little background that extends what I did a week ago,
big picture historical sequencing
and then a, a
sketch
of the
*Clashing Civilizations*
that
Sam Huntington, the late Sam Huntington
put forward in his,
in the piece you read.
The
last time we looked at
a
long
historical sequence
with the era of faith foundings
as a centerpiece and then
the voyages of discovery, the Treaty of Westphalia, and the emergence of
the
Western nation-state system as a grid, which
largely through the intermediation of colonialism
and then independence from colonialism
left its imprint
on every continent in the globe,
on the globe.
And, this thing turns orange to black. It's random.
The period of western colonial
occupation
becomes
the
pivotal period during which
cultures, most of all the metropolitan European cultures,
come into contact
with the rest of the world,
often in a highly coercive way,
sometimes in a constructive way, but at least as often in a destructive way
with the imposition of
western institutions
on
cultural traditions
and on faith traditions
which would,
in many cases, have
preferred to have been left alone.
In the same period,
over the same long sweep,
we have
an essentially static
economic condition for the poorest ten percent of places on earth.
I let it turn up a little in the last few hundred years.
There are
good economists who would say it actually turns down
that.
There's actually a, a, a new book a, a, a
very interesting new book called
*Making Poverty: A History*,
which
talk about how
there are
hundreds of millions of people
who's material condition is actually worse now than was the material condition
of similarly situated people at any time in the past. And, I, I
wouldn't dispute that.
I mean, I, I can't endorse it or dispute, but it
is arguable that the bottom of the world economically
is actually lower now than it was
in the bad old
Malthusian days.
Further left on the chart
the, what's pretty much indisputable
is that the richest ten percent
and one could as easily say thirty percent
of, of the world's places
have turned north
in a very dramatic way in
the last two hundred and twenty to two hundred and fifty years
and that the
consequent gap between top and bottom
is without doubt far greater today than it ever was in human history.
The number of really affluent people is way up,
but the distance between them and those who have not moved is
arguably on, in national aggregates so
easily on the order of fifty to one.
And, if you look at segments within
societies
is arguably on the order of five or ten thousand to one.
So you have enormous
inequality as
one of the
energy producers in the world economy
and one of the producers quite often a very negative energy,
and one of the.
Let me see what the numbers said.
Okay, five minutes. Thank you.
I'll make that easily.
The,
the
one, one
role that
some of the faith traditions
have taken and can take
is to
provide
help and aid
to those who are least advantaged by
capitalist global development.
Last time we also saw
with
an animated diagram,
complex animated diagram,
we saw the dynamics of this world revolution
and I pinned down the demographic aspect of it, which is terrifically important.
This diagram is something of a distraction because it's a,
it looks like the back of a radio,
but the, the,
the gist is
and this goes for,
this is now true for something like eighty five or ninety percent of the world,
that the evolution of the world has been from
societies where there are very high birth rates, and very high death rates,
and short lives in between on average
to a world in which there are
low birth rates,
low death rates,
and long lives in between.
Now when I say it applies to eighty five percent, I mean not that eighty five percent
have reached that end point,
but that eighty five percent are at least in stages two and three,
hurdling toward it,
and a few societies have gone beyond it
to the point where
births are
fewer than deaths
and society is aging and shrinking, Japan, for example,
but that's a big background and I think
very possibly a big background
to
the faith and globalization
story
and Professor Blair and
Professors Blair and Volf
will bring us.
This is
crude periodization of the last century.
Before World War II
international relations and conflict
was understood principally as a balance of power between
the
great, great military and
economic economy, a nations.
From about
the Yalta Treaty forward
the Cold War became the dominant organizing frame
and if Sam Huntington is to be believed
and I think he is, I think he's something like sixty percent right
the
period
that followed the Cold War
is one in which
culture,
faith,
identity,
race,
and an overlay of class differences
to defined economically
and that overlay is often
unexpressed, but terrifically important.
It's an awful lot easier
to become a suicide bomber
if you're
substantial, you have no substantial material prospects
in the world.
This is one
geographic rendering of Huntington's story.
The West shown in what turns out on this diagram to be brown.
The orthodox,
also brown,
slightly darker, I guess.
Latin America
to be
what it is.
Sub-saharan Africa to be purple.
Islamic, Islamic and Hindu blocks are
barely differentiated in
mustard color.
The Cynic block is
visible as China.
The Buddhist blocks and, and
Huntington waffles on whether Buddhism is a separate
civilization
and then you've got Japan.
And he posits
that there will be two main kinds of conflicts involving these
civilizations or blocks.
One of them will be core state versus core state.
So, for example,
India versus China or
the United States
versus
an Islamic
core state.
The other kind of conflict he posits is
what he calls fault line
conflict, which is
at the geographic boundaries between these blocks,
smaller states
and non-state actors,
and non-state actors become very important actually,
may
fight one another
and may engage in other forms of conflict. And final slide.
This is
one attempt to summarize the main lines of conflict
which Huntington
believes,
believed,
since he died recently,
will form
the dominant
axes of conflict
in the foreseeable future.
It looks like Latin America is blessed by this theory.
What's wrong with Huntington is,
well, I mean, it's a, it's a,
a ridiculously ambitious theory.
And, time's up, okay.
It's a ridiculously ambitious theory and
it's wrong in many parts because there's a great deal of conflict within civilizations.
Right, within one civilization bloc,
all kinds of things happen that Huntington gives no account of.
I'm finished and the floor is yours.